today we're talking about minecraft
getting some cute new blocks how the
sequel to jedi fall in order might be
revealed soon and more
let's start with a minecraft beta update
for players participating in minecraft's
beta program you're getting some cool
additions one of which is a new block
called frog light which is an
interesting new alternative to sea
lanterns and other light blocks these
blocks emit light and can be obtained by
luring a frog close to a small magna
cube the frog will then eat the cube and
a frog like block will drop there are
three types of frog like blocks and each
frog variant will cause a different one
to drop these types are pearlescent
verdant and ochre and can be placed in
different directions frogs and tadpoles
also have new audio and animations that
really help bring this new mob to life
and tadpoles now have a panic goal that
will help them find water if they get
stuck on land some other changes
included in this beta are coral now
generates in the deeper depths of warm
oceans and skeleton horsemen now
pathfind correctly among other things
switching gears to some star wars news
star wars jedi fallen order is getting a
sequel and according to reporter jeff
grubb it will be announced before e3
2022 speaking on today's episode of grub
snacks on gamespot's sister site giant
bomb grubb said quote expect to hear
about the game in a significant way
before e3 he added that there is a
chance that the game is released in 2022
but the more likely bet is that it will
arrive in early 2023 2019's jedi fallen
order was developed by titanfall studio
respawn and sold more than 10 million
copies making it one of the most
commercially successful star wars games
in history a sequel has been rumored for
some time and respawn recently hired
halo infinite multiplayer designer
patrick wren to work on star wars ea is
no longer the exclusive publisher of
star wars games on console as lucasfilm
and disney are now working with other
companies as well for example ubisoft is
making an open world star wars game
while quantic dream is creating a title
called star wars eclipse
and speaking of games we may hear more
about soon reporter tom henderson wrote
on twitter quote multiple people have
confirmed that the rumored remake of the
last of us for ps5 is quote nearly
finished and might launch in the second
half of 2022. separately vgc said it
heard the same thing from its own
sources about the remake of the last of
us for ps5 launching in the latter half
of 2022 additionally henderson said the
idea with all these last of us related
projects is to quote drum up hype for
the upcoming last of us tv show for hbo
starring pedro pascal's joel and bella
ramsay as ellie the show is in
production now but doesn't have a
release date during ces 2022 this week
naughty dog's neil druckmann said the
studio was quote dying to show off
multiple games it has in development but
didn't give any hints or clues as to
what those games are the next release
from naughty dog will be uncharted
legacy of thieves collection which
launches january 28th for ps5 and later
on pc so are you in that minecraft beta
program and are you loving those new
frog lights let me know in the comments
below and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you